there are dozens of frameworks besides
bootstrap available foundation for by
ZURB and yeah mo for by Dirk Jessie
provide huge sets of features comparable
to bootstrap you will find everything
from responsive grid systems and
nice-looking buttons to JavaScript
modules for interactive elements like
drop-down menus and carousels if you
need simplicity other frameworks like
960 grid SUSE and frameless provide
their own grid systems without the
overhead of additional features
bootstrapped is currently one of the
most popular frameworks and actually
that's why we're using it it does
however include some advanced
functionality you might never need the
good news is that because it's so robust
after you've mastered bootstrap you'll
be able to pick up other simpler
frameworks with very little effort to
learn more about bootstrap and other
frameworks check out the links in the
instructors notes